Hey guys,
so this is the launch of the first
wisecrack pilot for 2018.
We've got a couple of them in the works.
We will work really hard on him,
but most importantly we want to know
what you guys think,
so let us know what you think in the
comments and enjoy the show.
Sometimes it's the details of a film
that matter most likely a single shot,
a needle drop.
I see a little line of dialogue is
looking at your kid a sudden cut what
seemed like insignificant choices often
say more in under 20 seconds than other
films say into ours.
In this new format,
we'll be studying these seemingly
trivial pieces revealing how even the
smallest elements can bring layers of
meaning to a piece of art.
Welcome to wise cracks the film,
the wolf of Wall Street
and sell me this pen,
the closing shot of the wolf of Wall
Street.
This pen works and I just used simple
push in and crane up.
Well,
what if I told you this shot changes the
meaning of the entire film?
This pen works and I personally,
as a client describes the pin,
is voice drowns out and solemn music
kicks in.
Up to this point,
the film is utilized,
poppy,
upbeat,
hits to underscore the debauchery,
the amnesia phase,
so why the sudden shift to something
more serious and meditative.
For most of its three hour run time,
the wolf of Wall Street revels in Jordan
Belfort's access his yacht,
his women,
his drugs,
his parties,
the lifestyle paid for by defrauding
investors.
That is until the FBI circles in seizing
Belfort's cash and sending them away to
prison for four years,
but unlike similar films where the
corrupt Wall Street broker gets locked
up and justice is served,
the wolf of Wall Street is absent any
overt moralizing Belford prison time is
a cakewalk and he doesn't even serve his
full sentence.
In the end,
nothing has changed.
Belfort to still selling and the people
well,
they're still buying,
but this is just the tip of the iceberg.
The final shot can be interpreted in a
number of ways,
but here are our three favorites.
One,
the final shot holds up a mirror to us
movie goers.
Viewing the film,
notice there's eight backlight behind
the seminar that evokes a projector
shining on the back of an audience.
So what does this mean?
Well,
it may be easy to lay the blame solely
on Jordan for all the moral depravity,
wolf of Wall Street,
but perhaps the final shot,
the blame not only on Belford,
but on us and the culture that allows
and encourages his behavior.
He divorced me,
but yeah,
let's do it.
Early on,
Belford says,
we person you're on the phone with,
they want to get rich and they want to
get rich quickly.
They don't want something familiar.
We may feel dignified because we're not
crawling on the ground on quileutes,
but truth is Jordan scam wouldn't work
if we didn't share his dream of getting
rich quickly,
wanting something or nothing.
Y'all want to be just like him.
Scorsese is essentially calling us out.
We've just spent three hours partying
with laughing and reveling in his
experts.
It's no wonder Jordan doesn't suffer any
punishments in the end because after
all,
we revel in everything he does.
Living vicariously through him,
wishing that we could live his life too.
To all these people staring intently at
one person hanging on his every word
remind you of something.
We're going to go there.
Scorsese,
a devout Catholic,
has spent much of his career exploring
faith in his films,
yet in the wolf of Wall Street
characters worship at the altar of
something else.
Money
the camera holds on these people,
each one and focus so we can see they're
painfully average faces.
Desperate plain looking.
People looking for meaning,
desiring that which can elevate them
above their mundane existence.
Iscore,
Scorsese,
cynically likening,
be transformative power of faith to the
transformative power of money,
except the Almighty never promised a
million bucks in eight easy steps.
Three,
one if by solidly portraying a crowd
that warships Jordan,
despite his detestable actions,
scorsese suggests something really
sinister that we actually like being
taken advantage of.
French philosophers,
John Francois Leotard famously said as
much the English unemployed did not
become workers to survive.
They enjoyed the hysterical masochistic,
whatever exhaustion it was hanging on in
the minds,
in the foundries,
in the factories in hell.
They enjoyed it,
enjoyed the mad destruction of their
organic bodies,
the decomposition of their personal
identity.
You are lower than pond scum,
enjoyed the disillusion of their
families and villages,
and enjoyed the new monsters,
anonymity of the suburbs in the pubs in
the morning and evening.
So could this closing image indicate the
voluntary submission of the masses who
not only don't mind white collar
criminals stealing their money,
but find a perverse enjoyment in their
banal existence under the heel of the
Jordan Belfort's of the world.
This one single shot is emblematic of
just how complex the wolf of Wall Street
is as a true totem of our culture of
access.
The film defies easy answers.
This format is a bit of a test for us,
so let us know what you think in the
comments and as always,
guys,
thanks for watching peace.
So hope you guys enjoyed that.
We've got a whole bunch of pilots on the
slate this year.
This is just one of them.
We've got another one coming out in
about a month.
Also next month.
We're doing the next in this series,
which is on the shining,
so be sure to be on the lookout for
that.
This one was really special to us.
Uh,
as you know from watching our channel,
we love movies.
This was an opportunity for us to take
our love for movies to the next step.
So we wanted to leave you guys a little
behind the scenes on how it was that we
put this thing together and the big crew
that it took to make this thing
possible.
So enjoy the behind the scenes and we'll
see what the next one and about a month.
Thanks guys.
Hey,
what's up guys?
We're on the set of project.
I'm wearing something I would never
wear,
but it's for the shoot is behind the
scenes,
so hope you guys enjoy.
We're doing this very interesting thing
today.
We're working on the shining through.
Jared and I were brainstorming on how we
can come up with something that had a
little more production value,
right?
To take the idea of a video essay,
but we're talking about a theme
typically or philosophy in movies and
now instead it's like how can we talk
more about technique and style and do it
in a way that's different from most
other video assets you find on the
Internet Lot,
rode microphones and digital spot
supporting us.
Your donation and your health and your
support means everything to us.
You guys will be possible for us to try
and continue to develop wise crack,
to continue to stretch the brand.
Try and make it into something more and
more special and for all of you that
support us on this journey and to try
and make it the best it can be.
Thank you so much and hopefully you guys
enjoy our new efforts.